silvia quer estimar la media de la edad
de todos los profesores de su
universidad ella tomó una muestra
aleatoria simple de 20 profesores ok
esto es importante de un total
aproximado de 700 cada profesor en la
muestra le indicó a silvia su edad la
distribución de los datos fue asimétrica
a la derecha con una media muestral de
38 75 ella está considerando usar sus
datos para construir un intervalo de
confianza que le permite estimar la
media de la edad de los profesores de su
universidad qué condiciones se están
cumpliendo para construir un intervalo
te elige todas las que correspondan
así que pausa el vídeo y ve si lo puedes
contestar tú solo tratemos de responder
esto juntos
si por aquí tenemos a los 700 profesores
que hay en la universidad de silvia
déjame poner que son 700 lo que nosotros
queremos hacer es calcular la media de
la edad de estos profesores pero silvia
no puede preguntarle a los 700
profesores por lo que toma una muestra
aleatoria simple de 20 profesores
entonces n va a ser igual a 20 y con
estos 20 profesores ella obtiene una
media de la muestra de 38 puntos 75
idealmente ella quiere construir un
intervalo t un intervalo de confianza
usando el estadístico t y ese intervalo
de confianza se va a ver más o menos así
tendríamos a la media de la muestra que
es x con sombrero
al menos el valor crítico multiplicado a
su vez por la desviación estándar de la
muestra dividida entre la raíz cuadrada
de n y bueno usamos un estadístico t una
tabla t y una distribución tema cuando
queremos crear intervalos de confianza
para la media y desconocemos la
desviación estándar de toda la población
pero podemos calcular la desviación
estándar de la muestra ahora bien para
que éstos se cumplan hay tres
condiciones tal y como vimos cuando
estudiamos los intervalos z la primera
es que nuestra muestra sea una muestra
aleatoria lo cual nos lo dicen aquí ella
tomó una muestra aleatoria simple de 20
profesores así que estamos cumpliendo
esta condición
es justo lo que me dice es la opción a
los datos obtuvieron a partir de una
muestra aleatoria de la población así
que vamos a seleccionar esta primera
opción de lujo la siguiente condición es
la condición de normalidad déjame
apuntarlo ahora la condición de
normalidad cuando estamos haciendo un
intervalo tema es más restrictiva ya que
necesitamos suponer que la distribución
muestral de medias es aproximadamente
normal y hay dos maneras de validar esto
si el tamaño de la muestra
mayor o igual a 30 el teorema del límite
central establece que en este caso la
distribución muestral de las medias sin
que nos importe cuál es la distribución
original de la población ahora ella no
cumple eso porque aquí dice ella tomó
una muestra aleatoria simple de 20
profesores de un total aproximado de 700
así que por el momento esto no pinta
bien pero esta no es la única manera de
cumplir con la condición de normalidad
la otra manera de cumplir esta condición
cuando tenemos un tamaño de la muestra
menor que 30 es que la distribución
original de edades sea aproximadamente
normal o inclusive con que sea
aproximadamente simétrica con respecto a
la media así que también lo voy a poner
por acá
aproximadamente simétrica esto con
respecto a la media pero si chequeamos
el texto nos dicen que la distribución
fue asimétrica a la derecha eso
establece entonces que el conjunto de
los datos que obtenemos a partir de la
muestra no es simétrica con respecto a
la media y es improbable que la
distribución original de edades no sea
una distribución normal veamos por qué
es muy probable que tengas profesores
cuya edad sea 30 años más que la media
es decir 68.75 68 y tres cuartos de años
pero es imposible que tengas profesores
cuya edad sea 30 años menor que la media
de hecho eso es lo que está ocasionando
este sesgo a la derecha así que no se
cumple la condición de normalidad y por
lo tanto no podemos afirmar que nuestra
distribución muestral es aproximadamente
así que voy a cancelar esta opción
inciso c
las observaciones pueden considerarse
independientes hay dos maneras para
cumplir esta condición la primera es que
si el muestreo lo hicimos con reemplazo
cada vez que entrevistamos a uno de los
profesores después de preguntarle su
edad lo incluimos nuevamente en el grupo
y podríamos elegir la otra vez hasta que
obtengamos una muestra de 20 profesores
aparentemente no se hizo esto no parece
que haya hecho un muestreo con reemplazo
ahora aunque hagas un muestreo sin
reemplazo la regla del 10% establece que
mientras el tamaño de la muestra sea
menor o igual al 10% del tamaño de la
población estamos bien y bueno observan
n es igual a 20 y como el 10% de 700 es
70 entonces el tamaño de la muestra es
o igual al 10%
por lo que se puede considerar
independiente y también voy a
seleccionar esta opción así que ya
tenemos las dos condiciones que se
cumplen lo principal por lo que nuestro
intervalo tema no es correcto es que no
podemos considerar que la distribución
muestral se comporte como una
distribución normal por ahora es todo en
este vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente